You have something I want.
Who's this guy?
You may think you have some idea of what you are in possession of.
But you do not.
Kuiil, are you back to the ship yet?
They're on to us.
Kuill, come in!
In a few moments, it will be mine.
Kuiil, do you copy!
Kuiil!
It means more to me, than you will ever know.
Kuiil, are you there!
Come in Kuiil!
Kuiil, come in!
Kuiil, are you there!
Do you copy?
Kuiil!
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my new Mandalorian Episode
7 Ending video.
Because next week is the finale.
There's so much stuff coming up.
Be sure to subscribe if you're brand new to
my channel.
I'll be doing videos for the mandalorian during
the off season.
While we waiting for Season 2 to get here.
But they're well into shooting
season 2.
I'll do
more on
that
stuff after
I
do my Finale video next week.